it's been the driest eight months in
more than 40 years that's reduced
reservoirs into mud banks
nowhere is officially in drought but
some areas are cracking under dry
conditions
most of england has already moved into
what we term prolonged dry weather
status and this is the first stage of a
drought now there is no single
definition of drought
and my advice is don't wait for it to
happen we are already in prolonged dry
weather and therefore we would already
look to the public and the users of
water to start taking action now
today there was confirmation that water
companies particularly in the south of
england were enacting drought plans
permits could allow extra river water to
be pumped into reservoirs to maintain
supply if needed a hosepipe ban has been
introduced in the isle of man and there
are new emergency water measures for
farmers who are struggling to keep crops
alive
the downside of the heat here is it's
actually almost forcing it to ripen a
little bit earlier than it would do
do otherwise so we would have expected
that we would be harvesting this
probably at the end of the first week in
august
i suspect we'll be
in here in the first week at the
beginning of the first week in august so
we're you know the crops ripened earlier
it's pretty much died on its feet
we may not be in drought but the impact
of this dry weather can be seen even in
areas more used to wetter weather
yorkshire reservoirs are nineteen
percent lower than usual for this time
of year
so have you ever seen it as low no no
this is the lowest i've seen this you
could barely fish this
and the only reason i'm here fishing
this is because
i can't fish the rivers this is because
the rivers are
almost dry
water companies have had to manage both
a decrease in the supply of water during
this prolonged dry spell but also a
spike in demand because of the record
temperatures that we've been seeing we
know with climate change that these
extremes of weather are going to become
more frequent so the question is is
there the resilience in place now or
planned in order to deal with these
hotter drier summers
households are being urged to use less
water but some see this as a short-term
fix
things that an ordinary person can do
store rain water recycle water use grey
water but ultimately there's not really
much we can do without any adherence of
net zero policies or indeed
net zero policies we haven't seen any of
this for now further water restrictions
aren't planned but may have to be
introduced if significant rain doesn't
come and this dry spell turns into
drought catternovatsi sky news